activación de las redes 5g en vivo en
parís y otras ocho ciudades francesas la
próxima generación de datos móviles
promete una velocidad de transmisión
hasta 10 veces más rápida que la 4g con
mucho menos retraso en el tiempo de
conexión los proponentes esperan que sea
crucial para el desarrollo de vehículos
autónomos intervenciones médicas y
fábricas conectadas junto con mejores
experiencias de realidad virtual y
entretenimiento pero su despliegue se ha
enfrentado a un importante retroceso en
francia debido a la preocupación por el
aumento de la demanda de energía un
creciente problema de residuos
eléctricos y la explotación de recursos
no renovables junto con un temor a la
pérdida de privacidad en medio de la
creciente recolección de datos y el
potencial impacto en la salud por una
mayor exposición electromagnética
podríamos pedir que se prohíba a las 5 g
pero solo pedimos un debate un estudio
sobre el impacto de la sonda 5g queremos
información sobre el impacto en la salud
y el efecto en la demanda de energía
estas preocupaciones han llevado a
docenas de funcionarios franceses a
pedir una moratoria de la 5g mientras
tanto las teorías de conspiración que
vinculan
con el kobe 19 han contribuido a unos 50
ataques incendiarios de antenas 5g en
todo el país los operadores de redes
franceses han desembolsado cerca de 28
mil millones de euros al estado por
bloques de frecuencia 5g pero el país
está actualmente muy por detrás de
muchos vecinos europeos en su despliegue
hasta ahora se han instalado menos de
500 antenas la autoridad de
telecomunicaciones en francia quiere que
dos tercios de la población tenga acceso
a 5g para 2025 con un acceso total que
no llegaría hasta 2030